Ali Nelson cared for her family with a
good job working as an optician in
Washington DC that is until her employer
laid her off
we stayed open as long as we could until
you know it's just got to be too much
and our boss is pretty much said you
know we're gonna have to shut down until
further notice and so that's kind of
where we're at right now so not for me
it's a small company so we're not
getting paid
Nelson is part of the nearly 3.3 million
Americans who filed for unemployment
claims in late March government
economists think the kovat 19 pandemic
could put as many as a third of
Americans out of work those most at risk
the 67 million who work in the service
sector the so-called gig economy and the
entertainment industry antonella's had
been living the dream in Los Angeles
voiceover work dancing acting but with
social distancing Nell the norm it's
almost impossible for antonella's to
teach or perform so it's pretty scary
somehow shameful which is odd depressing
and did I say scary so depression scared
of fright and Shane or what I'm cycling
through and I can't explain the shame to
you Michael Hicks of Ball State
University in Indiana says the pandemic
will for some workers to find new
careers so I think there's gonna be a
lot of reprogramming by individuals from
those occupations to deal with people
that maybe aren't high skilled into or
high skilled medical or other fields
changing careers for Ali Nelson who's
already in health care may not happen
but she says people have a new
understanding of what it means to
survive this is a proof that people are
living paycheck to paycheck
and now something like this happens and
people aren't prepared for it you can't
be hoping the crisis does lead to a more
systemic economic change in society
Rosalind Jordan al-jazeera Washington